sundays at nine eastern and pacific
next author and journalist ken
silverstein comments on the american
political system
he's the co-author with alexander coburn
of the new book washington babylon
in the book they critique congress and
the presidency
he spoke recently at borders books and
music in bailey's crossroads virginia a
suburb of washington dc
mr silverstein is a contributor to the
nation and co-editor of the periodical
counter punch
okay so can everybody hear me
is this loud enough for everybody
can you hear in the back
okay i just want to welcome you folks
coming to tonight's event my name is
john ray i help coordinate the events
with colleen holt who unfortunately
couldn't be here this evening
um
tonight's event we have ken silverstein
who will be discussing his book
washington babylon and just a little
background on ken uh since 93 he's been
co-editor of the
newsletter counterpunch which is a
bi-weekly which is right here and he'd
be more than happy to share some
information about that he's been
co-editor with alexander cockburn who is
also the co-author of the book
washington babylon
counterpunch has been described as a
hard-hitting
newsletter exposing the dirt and behind
the scenes corruption of the political
world of washington dc and has won
praise from diverse publications such as
the new york post and the village voice
the stories from the newsletter have
been picked up by the new york times the
washington post and various other
publications
in addition to that it has been
nominated for a number of awards
um previous to this uh ken has worked as
a
as a correspondent for the associated
press for five years in rio de janeiro
in brazil and he has also written for
various publications such as harper's
the nation interview
and the sunday telegram
um with all that in mind i would just
like to welcome ken but before we get
started i just want to take note that
for those of you who might be a little
overwhelmed by the corruption and the
dirt and the smell of the issues that
will be forthcoming for the first first
first 15 publication first 15 uh
purchases we will be offering air
fresheners to make the drive home a
little more
easy on the sole if you will okay
there we go
well first i want to thank you all for
coming i'm
impressed that you've heard about the
book because we've had a hard time
getting the press in the united states
anyway to to write about the book and to
review the book it's very curious in in
london
every major newspaper has reviewed the
book or written about the book some
favorably and some not so favorably but
they've all
treated it as a serious word
in the united states we other than the
alternative press
uh for the boston phoenix and
the texas observer
we've been reviewed in exactly one
newspaper the charleston gazette of
south carolina
and meanwhile you see
all sorts of books that
i think are a lot less important um i
mean i'm not going to tell you that the
book we wrote is the greatest book that
ever was but i think it's more important
than say the choice by bob woodward i
mean this is a book about
the 1996 political campaign that came
out six months
before the election and before even the
candidates were nominated i just don't
think that's a serious book i don't know
if any of you saw newsweek magazine ran
an excerpt of course because newsweek is
owned by
uh the washington post company and
the the uh the poll quote one of the
poll quotes for for the woodward book
had christopher dodd the senator from
connecticut being astonished because he
heard on
his phone
clinton shuffling cards
in the background it was midnight and
clinton was playing solitaire and i
thought you know if the best pull foot
you can get is
chris dodd astonished at clinton playing
solitaire you know the book is a dog and
yet this book is
widely reviewed everywhere the other
book that i find sort of funny is um
the jeffrey biernbaum book i can't
remember the title now i like jeffrey
biernbaum's work he did a very good book
called the lobbyist but he's now written
a book that's been reviewed everywhere
it's in the windows of stores
everywhere and it's about the private
stress
the the terrible stress of of working in
the white house the private agony of
white house employees and again i mean
i'm terribly sorry that dede myers was
under terrible stress and that her blood
pressure was constantly going up when
she worked at the white house but
i just can't believe that that's a more
serious book
than ours and again you may by the book
you may hate the book but it's a serious
book we
basically
took the post watergate period in
american history
if you look back at watergate actually
this was a moment of great hope in
american politics because nixon had been
evicted from the white house you had
this system a lot of people said it
works you know nixon
was caught for at least some of his
crimes
the press bob woodward uh
at the head of the pack did uh did a
good job in investigating the corruption
of the nixon years and nixon was thrown
out and so ironically if you look at the
state of american politics today
watergate looks very very good indeed i
mean you had the system that seemed to
be working in many ways and even the
nixon presidency
next to the clinton presidency was very
positive in some ways you had all sorts
of environmental legislation being
passed in in the post watergate period
there were all sorts of reform measures
passed including campaign finance reform
the system was supposed to be
cleaned up
and so
today you look at what happened that's
what we tried to do in the book we tried
to trace the political intellectual and
ethical decline of this city
post-watergate
and it's a pretty sordid picture we
focused on the press
we focused on congress
on lobbyists there are now some 80 000
lobbyists
flying their trade here in in the
washington area and you know typically
they charge 300 an hour 350 an hour
probably not many people here can pay
their rates but
the wealthy
people in this country the corporations
can pay those rates and so they seem to
do much better in washington than most
of us we looked at
the
pentagon which we dubbed pork central
because of the tremendous waste of money
that goes on at the pentagon we looked
at even the public intersect of the
environmental movement and the
presidency and we didn't come away with
a very positive picture
we uh
we started off by by looking at the
press
and i don't want to romanticize the
press i think that the mainstream media
in any country at any time is basically
there to faithfully reflect
the views of elite opinion and sometimes
the press tends to be a little bit more
aggressive and that tends to be when
there are
moments of uh a split in in elite
opinion like at the time of watergate
there were many conservatives even who
wanted nixon to go and so you tended to
see more aggressive reporting
but it is true that
20 30 40 years ago the press tended to
be a lot more aggressive than it is
today
and i think one of the problems is that
reporters in this town today
are so keen on gaining access and they
think that
you know they they to get their calls
returned they fear being a little bit
too risky or too impolite it's always
funny people will always say to me well
don't you worry if you know you don't
get the calls returned and i think it's
sort of silly because
if alan greenspan doesn't return my
phone call i don't think that really
does any harm to my work i don't think
that if alan greenspan returns my call
he's going to tell me anything terribly
interesting
he and so the whole idea that you have
to have access that you have to be
prudent and polite and
you know and get your calls returned i
think it's a myth of journalism that
that
you know we you have to be very careful
in any case
it's curious
today the beltway press score has been
completely bought off it seems to me
during clinton's six first six months in
office he held a whole series of of uh
private dinners
at the white house and guests were
treated to fine wines and they were
feasted on pan-seared lamb and you know
these were private soirees for the elite
is what the washington post described
them as
and
there were many politicians in the
audience and many lobbyists but there
were also many journalists
and
you know it's curious because
the people who attended sometimes
afterwards tended to write fairly
sympathetic things about
bill and hillary clinton for example
charlie peters of the washington monthly
attended one of these fine meals and he
came away writing a very nice piece
about hillary clinton
and r.w apple the the the bureau chief
of the new york times here in washington
he just a few nights
well actually in fact the next day he
had a piece in the new york times
that
clinton came in late to this meal and he
said that many of the guests were
already through their second glass of
jordan cabernet sauvignon and their beef
wellington but clinton there was pain
etched on clinton's face because he was
going to have to dismiss poor lani
guinere the assistant attorney general
at that time and so a few days later
apple wrote this very sympathetic
portrayal about the terrible agony that
that bill clinton was going through i
mean after all he'd been late to for the
beef wellington and all i think that
when journalists go to these events when
they
when when they attend these events at
the white house when they think it's
important to be on such favorable terms
to people in power it influences their
reporting and i think you've seen that
time and time again
um in the way the the beltway press
corps
covers politics in this town
and
apple of the new york times another
interesting example about him
this is another way that
the whole idea of access i think
corrupts the sort of reporting you see
apple did an interview with howard kurtz
of the washington post
and kurtz asked him about his
friendships with people like robert
strauss who's one of the top power
brokers in town he's the lobbyist at the
aiken gump law firm
and zabiganu brzezinski the former
national security advisor and and apple
said rather forthrightly yeah if they
told me the story i was working on was a
bunch of crap i'd be sort of hesitant to
put it forward
and i just wonder about the wisdom of
the bureau chief of the new york times
here in washington
thinking that if
someone like robert strauss told him
something was a bunch of crap that gee
maybe i better not write that story i
don't know that to me does not sound
like the sort of independent watchdogs
that that we're looking for and that we
desperately need
you know there are all sorts of rewards
i think for for people who who for
reporters
who who toe the line who who are
responsible reporters i mean they they
do gain access i mean indeed they do
get invited to to all the special events
i mean you know the economic reporters
that that do a nice job end up getting
invited by ellen greenspan to watch the
fireworks display on the fourth of july
from the roof of the federal reserve
which is supposed to be a you know
beautiful experience
and you you know you see the renaissance
weekend events people are probably
familiar with where
clinton spends his uh his his new year's
eve at this resort up in the south
carolina
and you see politicians and reporters
mingling and there was one pretty funny
story from 1993 where howard feynman of
newsweek
he attended renaissance weekend he
played touch football with bill clinton
he attended a workshop on
building an inner life and he lobbied
clinton to send chelsea his clinton's
daughter to uh sidwell friends where
tuition is eleven thousand dollars a
year
you know and and then just a few weeks
later with not too much self-reflection
i think feinman was on
washington week in review one of the the
talking head shows
and he said um
he said and i want to read this because
i want to make sure i get this right he
was talking about the political culture
of uh of little rock and he was saying
that politics in little rock was
different than here in washington it was
a small group of insiders he said they
have the money they've got the power
they're on a first name basis with each
other
and the line between public money and
private business is very fuzzy i mean
this is a guy who just spent this
exclusive weekend at in at hilton head
south carolina with clinton but he
somehow doesn't recognize his own town
when he makes this sort of commentary
now
another problem of course with the press
is that reporters now make a lot more
money than they did 30 40 and 50 years
ago i mean 75 000 is not an uncommon
salary for a beltway reporter these days
and it's funny because benjamin bradley
who was the washington post editor at
the time of watergate
he retired
from the post a few years ago and they
put him into this nice little job as i
can't remember the exact title but it
was like the assistant vice president
for
you know news production or some bogus
category that allowed them to pay him
over a million dollars as a bonus
and a healthy annual salary and bradley
said that um
reporters are more conservative than the
previous generation and i think there's
a very good reason for that they get
paid a hell of a lot better it's hard to
be conservative on 75 a week but 75
grand you begin to think of the kids in
the bank account the ira
and i think this is a very good point
though bradley isn't somewhat odd person
to be making the point but look at cokie
roberts
she makes thirty thousand dollars for a
single speech
before a business organization you know
it's very hard for me to believe that
cokey roberts is able to really
relate in any manner to quote the
average american and i don't want to get
you know i don't want to play poor and
tell you that i'm a poor starving person
who understands the welfare mothers you
know it's it's i can't say that i do but
i
you know i think that at a certain point
and i would if anyone wants to
investigate my irs return i'll be happy
to
to turn it over to you it's a fairly
modest salary with a fairly modest
lifestyle and i do think it makes a
difference when you're making thirty
thousand dollars for a single speech or
take diane sawyer
seven million dollars in a year she
makes from abc for prime time well it
was curious because diane sawyer gave a
uh she she there was an issue prime um
an episode primetime did on welfare
mothers and these terrible welfare
mothers now one case terrible abuse she
uncovered a welfare mother working two
jobs
and and probably making more than she
should to collect her welfare benefits
well this woman's salary income for the
year with with uh her welfare benefit
was sixteen thousand dollars which was
less than diane sawyer makes in in in a
single day so it's very hard for
me to uh you know treat diane sawyer as
a credible authority on welfare mothers
so this is the sort of thing you see
and i think
that's the sort of thing we go through
in the book
the press
again i don't want to romanticize the
press and say that at some point it was
a fierce watchdog it's always had a
fairly uh
cautious role but today i think it's
less aggressive than ever
and you don't see the hard-hitting
investigative reporting that you used to
see
even if it wasn't the uh
the rule but there were many many
exceptions
now after after we talked about the
press
we moved on to to congress
and
this book was published by verso which
is based in london
and you know
other countries don't have quite the
same sort of political system no doubt
in england private
corporations private companies and
wealthy individuals are able to
influence the political system but i
don't think
to anywhere near the same extent as they
are here it was funny because we were
we had to get the book
uh
fact checked for publication in the
united states and in london and in
london libel law is far stricter and so
they came back with all of these
questions they were very nervous about
publishing the book and one of the
questions they said was
you know you've got these cases in the
book where
a politician gets a campaign
contribution from a big company and then
in congress you see how they vote in
favor of that company can you back that
stuff up
this is the salient feature of the
contemporary american political system
that favors are bought and sold
very very easily and yet
over there they think boy this is
strange i mean this is really
unusual can you know can this possibly
be true but i'm sure as most of you know
the root problem with the american
political system is money and the
campaign finance system which nobody
seems to be able to fix
to run for a seat in the house of
representatives cost on average about
half a million dollars now
to run for a seat in the senate cost
almost five million dollars now where
you get that sort of money it's very
hard to raise five million dollars
you only you have only one place to go
and that's
wealthy individuals and especially the
big corporations
now
the
arms industry the weapons industry
outspends peace groups in terms of their
political contributions by twenty to one
the oil and gas industry outspends
environmentalists by ten to one so it's
very easy to decide if you're running
for public office and you need to raise
five million dollars
where
what sort of political rhetoric you
might campaign on and you know you're
you're not going to raise a lot of money
from lockheed if you're bashing the
pentagon and so i think because of the
enormous expense it's become extremely
difficult for any sort of real populist
reformer to run for public office it's
just too expensive i mean one amazing
fact that we
stumbled upon in researching this book
is that
out of a single zip code on new york
city's upper east side this is 1.021 and
for those of you who aren't familiar
with new york city the upper east side
is where a lot of very wealthy
individuals live wall street financiers
henry kissinger makes his home up on the
upper east side
but out of that one zip code comes more
political contributions than that which
comes out of each of 24 states
so that out of 1.021 comes more money
than idaho more money than out of
montana or south dakota or north dakota
i mean it's a staggering
amount of cash that politicians are able
to tap and it tells you something about
whose interests are going to be
represented in washington dc
now
you see that at the
if you examine individual members of
congress
you'll see the same sorts of of patterns
emerging in terms of their campaign
financing i mean think of two extremes
in congress i mean the
the the right wings poster boy is newt
gingrich i mean who who better
represents
the right wing in america than newt
gingrich on the on the other end of the
spectrum which doesn't go too far to the
other to the other side but to the
left-hand side
i mean you could there are a few but
richard gephardt certainly is considered
a liberal democrat i mean here's a guy
who's the democratic house leader
he
has opposed
gang rich at least rhetorically on on
issue after issue and in fact in
substance on some issues as well
but it's interesting because if you
examine their campaign finance records
there are more than 100 political action
committees that give money to both newt
gingrich and to richard gephardt
and i think that
that tells you a lot i think that
it's pretty clear
that if you're lockheed or if you're a t
you don't give money to richard gephardt
because you personally like richard
gephardt you give it because you think
you can get something in return
and i think it's it's it's pretty
striking that these two
ideological extremes in the united
states are basically funded by the same
the same interest
you'll see the same thing at the
presidential level of course which is
why in 1996
we basically do not have a choice in
this election i mean
the terms tweedledee and tweedledum were
never more appropriate than they are
today
yes you will find differences between
bill clinton and bob dole on certain
issues particularly on certain social
issues
which
are not unimportant but if you look at
the broad fundamental economic issues
confronting the united states
they are truly indistinguishable i mean
clinton
look at the issue like nafta
nafta
clinton unleashed his fiercest lobbying
effort of his entire presidency of his
entire presidency to push through nafta
which is an issue that 20 years ago most
democrats would have fiercely opposed
but now there's just no difference
between the parties
on nafta on get on welfare reform i mean
i must say that
clinton's
presidency
it's very hard for me to be surprised at
anything he does anymore it's hard to be
cynical but it was a bit of a shock to
see a democratic president basically end
the welfare system and to simply say
to all of these people
who
are dependent on
that income
goodbye you're gone you're not going to
get any help from us anymore i mean
you know when you see the democrats and
the republicans basically agreeing
on that sort of issue you know that the
choices are very limited you know
clinton then has the nerve to say well
we're going to uh
we will correct the excesses i mean sure
there are a few problems but we'll take
care of that i mean the republicans in
congress he's going to present a bill
and the republicans are going to agree
to a clinton bill to correct the
excesses of the welfare bill i mean
please you know this is just not going
to happen
and so
you know again if you look at the
financial records
and and the political outcome you see
that there just aren't many differences
back in 92
you had
eight men each supply more than a
hundred thousand dollars to both
bill clinton and and george bush the
republican candidate at that time you
know you had people like
uh dwayne andreas of archer daniels
midland and lodrick cook of of arco each
giving more than a hundred thousand
dollars to both parties
this year you see the same thing we've
got the republican convention going on
right now
in san diego the republican convention
is going to cost 12 million dollars it's
not really a political convention in the
sense of airing issues or having debate
or even in the terms of presenting
the candidates really the whole idea is
just to raise gobs and gobs and gobs of
money it's just a it's just a
fundraising another fundraising event
so they've they've raised 12 million
dollars
and i have a list of the donors
who paid for the convention which i
won't go through because it's too long
but just the a's alone and by the way
let me give credit where credit is due
this is from the center for responsive
politics a washington watchdog group
but you've got abbott laboratories
paying for the convention they gave the
republicans 91 eight hundred ten dollars
advanced micro devices gave thirty five
hundred dollars
and heiser bush has given the
republicans three hundred thirteen
thousand dollars archer daniels midland
three hundred thirty six thousand
dollars arko
six hundred thirty one thousand dollars
a t one million seventy two thousand
dollars
and of course all of these companies are
also big contributors to the democratic
party not quite as big in most cases but
very generous for example a t
gave
well not bad 786 thousand dollars to the
democrats and arko gave them about
320 000.
so this is these are not insignificant
sums of money
so what would you expect if the
conventions and the politicians are
basically bought and paid for by these
corporations you wouldn't expect there
to be too much difference
between the two parties and in fact one
more thing
i want to
you're
thinking that oh well the democrats get
less and there is some sort of
significant difference
consider the democratic national
committee trustee program this is a
program that the democrats offer to
their big donors these are people who
give as an individual five hundred
thousand fifty thousand dollars per year
or if they've raised a hundred thousand
dollars per year or more from other
sources well
if you manage to raise that amount of
money
this is what you get from the democratic
party the people's friend the great
populist party of franklin roosevelt you
get an invitation to participate in
foreign trade missions
which afford you opportunities to join
party leaders in meeting with business
leaders abroad
you get to travel throughout the country
and join senior administrative officials
in their private impromptu meetings
during their travels you get vip status
at the convention coming up in chicago
including tickets to restricted events
private parties and post-convention
celebrations
each of the trustees is actually
assigned a dnc a democratic national
committee staff member to assist them in
their personal request i know that all
of you have you know if you call
washington you immediately have somebody
dealing with your personal request
you all of the trustees receive a daily
political fax alert
and the annual they are all invited to
the annual trustee event with the
president in washington in two with the
vice president
and they're invited to two um annual
retreats with with high-ranking
democratic party officials
in the past
these
events have included a ski a ski trip to
aspen or the uh nantucket weekend where
the lucky invitees stay at the
white elephant inn and enjoy
time at the beach and golf and you know
they get to hobnob with top democratic
politicians i mean this truly you don't
have to be radical to say this is a
government that is for sale this is
literally
for sale
and
in many cases it's for sale for chump
change and these are pretty big
contributions in many cases but often
you'll find
that for a very small contribution
five thousand dollars if you dole out
five thousand dollars a year you may
find yourself
the lucky recipient of a big tax break
or some other benefit worth quite a bit
more than that i mean i don't know if
any of you remember when uh
packwood was evicted from the senate
because of the sexual harassment
deservedly evicted from the senate but
but in fact i mean he should have been
booted many many years ago for for
various other abuses i don't know if you
remember the
packwood diaries and where he talked
about one of his big
campaign contributors
out in oregon
who he said
he was hoping to put the hit on i think
actually one of the contributors he
wanted to
um his wife his ex-wife was was trying
to increase her alimony payments and so
pac would wanted to get her a job so she
wouldn't
be able to hit him up for as much money
i think it was this
this uh
this businessman he said i i
you know i i needed him to put her on
the georgie on the payroll and he was
fairly confident that this was going to
take place because
furman i believe his name was william
furman it's in the book if you want to
buy it
he said furman is you know he he's
terribly grateful for me for the 5
million
tax break i installed in the 1986 tax
bill i mean so
these are the sorts of favors that
that you find um are easy to buy in
washington dc if you have enough money
to to buy them
now i think does anyone can you tell me
what time it is i don't want to i want
to leave a lot of time
oh well then i want to stop right here
just
finally i'll
take your questions but i just i mean i
am here of course to relentlessly hawk
the book and so i do want to tell you
that there's much much more information
in the book that of course i haven't
discussed
and if you buy the book you'll find
inside you'll learn about the pictures
that henry kissinger desperately sought
to suppress that we've published here
in in the book
there um i can't really since um this is
being filmed i don't want to discuss the
nature of these photographs but you'll
immediately see why kissinger sought to
suppress them
you'll learn why senator larry pressler
south dakota is referred to by his
intimate friends as telephone pole
and as a hint i will tell you this has
nothing to do with the
telecommunications industry at all
though he does oversee it
you'll learn about john alexander
who was
the head of non-lethal research at los
alamos laboratories
the this position it's sort of
frightening because if you look into his
background you learn that at one point
in his life he was trying to teach esp
to dolphins and he was diving for the
lost island of atlantis but he was also
in charge of millions and millions and
millions of dollars to develop
non-lethal weaponry
and you'll also learn last but not least
about newt gingrich's college days at
tulane where newt the great opponent of
uh
social programs enrolled his kid at a
head start program and he also more
shockingly was led a campaign he even
led a protest where they burned the uh
burned an effigy the campus president
this was a campaign to ensure that a
student publication could publish nude
photographs so this is not the family
values sort of stuff that you would have
expected from nudie back in his college
days
anyway with that i will
open the floor to questions and take as
many as you have yeah yes i was
wondering what you thought of the uh
flat tax as promulgated by dick armey
and steve forbes do you think it's going
to go anywhere a modified flag tax
you know it's curious
the flat tax anything that's offered up
by steve forbes and dick army you have
to immediately feel tremendously
skeptical about
because let's face it steve forbes and
dick armey are not known for their
generosity to those in the lower tax
brackets
but it's so i don't think i doubt it
will go too far
um
simply because
people at the top are able to
get out of paying most of their taxes
anyway through various loopholes and so
i think the system the tax system
doesn't work for most people and i think
people are sympathetic to a flat tax in
fact because they dread
every year having to do their taxes they
go hey this looks pretty simple
but
i'm a bit skeptical about
about it largely because of who's behind
it
it could in fact under certain
circumstances work but i doubt if it
ever does get out of congress it'll pass
in a form that's terribly beneficial to
most of us
i saw a recent statistic that said the
corporation share the income tax in the
last 30 years had dropped
43 to 12
is that more or less true
i i mean i can't vouch for those precise
numbers but yeah i mean
the the amount of taxes paid by
corporations and wealthy individuals has
just plummeted of course
it started even before the reagan years
uh but
you know that trend picked up steam
immensely under ronald reagan i mean the
1986 tax bill which was
you know one of the leading uh drafters
of that was bill bradley who uh
is so widely revered here in washington
but that bill contained tremendous
favors for wealthy individuals so i
can't speak to those specific numbers
but that trend i know is entirely
accurate
go ahead
um
what do you propose like people should
do
to change the system where
the only way you can get elected is
through lots of money it's extremely
frustrating and you know i sometimes
feel bad about having even written this
book which basically contains all sorts
of
attacks
on the current political system and
not terribly much in the way of remedies
i think
that for one
though
that
despite the fact that some people might
read the book and go throw up their
hands and say oh
it's all
you know what's the point
our point is that in fact
first
you do need to get involved there are
certain issues that are fundamental i
mean campaign finance reform
is an issue that members of congress are
sensitive to if pressure is kept up on
them and i do think it's a fundamental
issue i don't think that that alone is
going to clean up the system
but there are
it would immensely improve the system if
there were real changes made in the
campaign finance system but
more importantly i get really frustrated
with people who insist
that they have to vote for the lesser of
two evils that that's the only choice we
have let's face it let's just vote for
mostly what i hear is bill clinton
we've got to vote for clinton to stop
bob dole well i can tell you that
in 1972
we've gone from 1972 where you had
richard nixon versus george mcgovern
which offered
some choice at least to a situation in
1996
where we have no choice at all and i
think partly that's because
people simply say
we've got to stick with a lesser of two
evils and so then you're stuck with it
forever and ever and ever i think that
people should
at every level
local state national look for an
alternative and don't think of it as a
wasted vote i think
that there is a real chance that the
american political system is really
going to get shaken up in the next few
years i do think
that there's a possibility that you'll
see the two-party system come crashing
down
you know perrault who i'm not a
tremendous admirer of
did get a significant chunk of the vote
he's going to run again you're going to
see third parties get a share of the
vote ralph nader
is running a curious campaign but he is
on the ballot he's going to be on the
ballot in probably 35 states nader is
the sort of person who could get five
percent of the vote and and and
that could shake up the system i think
you're going to
potentially see
within the next four years even by the
year 2000 or certainly after 2000 i
think there's a good chance you're going
to see the end of the two-party system
and and that will mean new choices i
think the best alternative is that you
know you get a nader with 20 percent of
the voter 10 of the vote not this year
necessarily but you know you build to so
that you've got
four or five or six different parties
competing
because then they have to offer
alternatives right now
the democrats and republicans don't
really have to offer too much of an
alternative because the third parties
can't compete the rules are rigged
against them but i think
to simply stay engaged to simply get
involved and to make sure that your vote
does count but not
by voting for somebody who you
personally can't stand but you can't
stand him
you know a little bit less than the
other guy so i you know i think it
look what you do in november as a start
oh
question um regarding pat buchanan
and his campaign
sorry i have a question regarding pat
buchanan and his uh campaign i was
wondering how someone like him
you know populist with um
uh
he was sort of uh
talking against nafta could raise that
kind of money
for a campaign national campaign well
i don't know how much
oh sorry he asked about pat buchanan who
he said ran as a populist
attacking nafta and got in free trade
yet managed to raise a lot of money
first i don't know how much money pat
buchanan raised but it wasn't anywhere
near as much as lamar alexander or bob
dole or the others secondly i bet a lot
of the money that buchanan raised came
from
you know complete right-wing kooks who
who liked pat buchanan they may not have
even been terribly sympathetic to his
position on free trade but they thought
yeah it's time we close the borders and
keep those immigrants out and and i bet
a lot of the money he raised came from
that crowd
and and thirdly it is very curious
that pat buchanan of all people was the
populist candidate in 1996 i mean
think of it corporate downsizing became
a big issue why because pat buchanan
made it an issue bill clinton certainly
wasn't going to and the press certainly
wasn't going to you know the press
doesn't make anything an issue unless
somebody calls a press conference to
discuss it and so pat buchanan did a
service
by making corporate downsizing and
corporate power a real issue in the
campaign
so i don't know if i'd look to buchanan
and say hey here's a guy who was a real
populist who who raised serious money
and competed i think he was able to
compete because he was the only person
in the campaign
republican or democrat
who actually had a corporate critique
and there are a lot of people in this
country who feel very angry about the
loss of economic opportunity who may
have responded to that and that alone
and it caused a big sting and then you
saw of course the immediate reaction
um
against buchanan
um you know the reaction that came
crashing down from the republican
establishment upon him and i am you know
i think anybody who reads the book will
know i'm not a big fan of pat buchanan
but
it's very interesting that he
was the only person this year who raised
those issues
um you i think you would yes
uh why did it take 15 years to
deregulate the icc the interstate
commerce commission they passed the act
in 1980 and was abolished december of
1995. well you know that's one of those
agencies and let's face it there is
bureaucracies do tend to become
entrenched and that was one of these
agencies that got itself a nice big
budget and it had a lot of friends in
the
industry that wanted to keep it afloat i
mean vernon jordan the uh you know
president clinton's golfing partner
i don't remember the precise details but
if anybody looks back into it vernon
jordan
was battling to
preserve
that agency at one point and you know it
had a lot of very powerful supporters
industries like to be regulated in fact
they like to a certain extent to um
to have these agencies because the
agencies generally are not terribly
rigorous i mean in fact the you know
there are all these right-wing think
tanks out there who are demanding the
abolition of the
food and drug administration
but even some of the big pharmaceutical
firms have said hey
we basically want the fda to be brought
you know
we don't want the fda to be able to
really do too much we don't want the fda
to be able god forbid to prevent us from
selling
drugs that we haven't tested adequately
but don't abolish it
you know because generally a lot of
these agencies
tend to be even even the fda tend to be
fairly sympathetic to uh industry i mean
i you know olestra this um
this fat substitute that procter gamble
just got
approved by the fda and this is a
product that potentially is very
dangerous i mean they've had to put
these black warning labels the even the
fda had to say well
you better put a
the warning label on the product because
you might have i can't remember how they
delicately phrased it but something like
intestinal difficulties or something
like this
um
but
you know you you you can see that the
fda i i foied some letters i did some
got some letters under the freedom of
information act
and you saw
most democrats and republicans in the
state of ohio or at least many of them i
don't want to say most
writing a letter to the fda urging that
they support a lester why because
procter gamble gives them all money for
their campaigns and procter and gamble
is based in ohio
and so
you know i mean the bureaucracies get
entrenched
they have friends and they have powerful
friends and it's hard to get rid of them
even some of the ones that are
completely inefficient a complete waste
of taxpayer money
yes the gentleman in their ear
oh yes
is bill clinton facing financial
personal and political
well
i wish i could answer that question i am
always amazed at how
many in the press and especially many
liberals
tend to want to sort of wish whitewater
away i mean i think white water is
pretty ugly i mean
white water now means a lot of things
but
at a minimum
you saw bill clinton
getting involved with some completely
sleazy business people in the state of
arkansas and trying to make a lot of
money
on his investments and basically doing
favors for these business people like
mcdougall
and so at a minimum it it's very very
very incestuous it's funny to me you
always hear
people defend
the clinton
they'll say um
gee how could whitewater have been a
crime i mean for god's sake they lost
money on the deal
you know well first off
they lost money and then hillary lied on
her tax forms
about
how much money she somehow managed a
corporate lawyer managed to confuse
interest in principle
and and and and and say that she had
lost all of it way more than they'd
actually lost so they could get this big
tax break
secondly
she did not
and he did not bill and hillary did not
go into the white water investment to
lose money they happened to lose money
but they wanted to make a lot of money i
mean there was that letter that hillary
wrote
to james mcdougall
where i'm quoting almost verbatim
this was in the mid-80s she said if
reaganomics works at all white water
could be the hemis the mecca of the
western hemisphere they didn't want to
lose money
you know it's sort of like a robber
going into court
and you know pleading for mercy saying
gee you know i only got off with 400 and
i spent 300 on my safe cracking tools
and i had to pay 600 accomplices i lost
money have mercy
they went into that deal to make a lot
of money
and so
i think there's a lot there that needs
to be looked into
um it's curious i'm sure most people are
aware of the uh news reports that james
mcdougall
may be cooperating with
the uh independent council kenneth starr
if that happens
you know that changes the equation quite
a bit
uh obviously james mcdougall had a lot
of business deals with with bill and
hillary and that could make a big
difference in the
investigation but
you know i wouldn't want to predict
because i just don't know what mcdougall
has to say and i don't know how things
are going to come out
uh but certainly there's
i i don't think it's the non-scandal
that a lot of liberals want to say it is
you know that the other line that's
pretty funny is
white water is a cover-up without a
crime
well excuse me but
a cover-up is a crime
if you lie to federal authorities and if
you block an investigation if you cover
up
you're subject to criminal penalties so
that's a pretty shabby excuse
yeah
i frequently hear people say how liberal
the media is do you share that viewpoint
well 20 years ago i would have said
that's completely bogus
i don't share that viewpoint if you look
at i mean obviously if you look at the
op-ed pages of every major american
newspaper you will see a tremendous
conservative bias
you know you'll see william sapphire and
in the washington post you've got james
glassman and robert samuelson and george
will thank you i mean there's a
tremendous slant
there in favor of conservatives um you
know david broder for god's sake is
considered liberal
um i mean this is a guy who
is
i mean he's being saying centrist is is
being too kind i mean he's a pretty
conservative fellow but he's considered
liberal on the op-ed page
at the level of the publishing world of
course it's it's very conservative as
well
you know catherine graham obviously is
not a rabble rouser you know we heard
stories in the course of investigating
the book about
catherine graham
having lunch with
henry kissinger and coming back to the
newsroom and sort of loudly exclaiming
that the post coverage on nafta had been
too sympathetic to the nafta opponents
which is anybody who read the washington
post during that time can attest it was
tremendously pro-nafta
it is true though i think i mean there's
no getting around it
that at the level of the reporter and
the average beltway reporter most
beltway reporters are probably democrats
and quote liberals but i do think you've
got to keep in mind that liberal what
does liberal mean these days it means
that you're
pro-choice
you're in favor of abortion
and you may be you know in favor of gay
rights it doesn't mean much more than
that today liberal also means pro-free
trade pro-nafta i mean
so
you know the way liberal is defined in
the united states in 1996 i guess that's
to a certain extent a fair critique
at that lower level but certainly i mean
it's it's totally crazy to say that the
news media
is this you know terribly liberal bunch
and that they're trying to pollute the
minds of the poor americans with all of
these crazy liberal beliefs i mean
that's
that's crazy that's just i mean i don't
know how anybody can take that seriously
sorry
it seems to me that the um word liberal
it sort of has by calling the press
liberal you sort of force it to go the
other way because the presumption is
that well the liberal media or the
um
you know digging up all this dirt and so
on
absolutely it's a threat and it's an
effective threat you know i don't know
how many people remember but back in the
mid 1980s
el salvador and nicaragua were very very
very big issues in the united states
now
shirley christian
the egregious new york times x new york
times reporter who was the most
you know sympathetic to the most
conservative right-wing elements in
in latin america
wrote a famous piece
in the washington journalism review
where she attacked raymond bonner of the
new york times
and
karen de young of the washington post
for reporting on a massacre at almazote
that she said
that was a lot of it and that they were
sympathetic to the sandinistas
and
you know that they had all this biased
reporting and they were tommy simpson on
and on and on
well this had a chilling effect and this
really had a big effect raymond bonner
in fact ended up being driven out of the
times basically
and
it silenced a lot of reporters working
in central america and of course
it came out many years later that the el
mazote massacre where the salvadoran
army the united states ally
had systematically slaughtered
i think it was about 700 peasants who
were just executed and buried in mass
graves and so these reporters had done
their job but they were red-baited
as you said when you throw that out it
makes a reporter think twice about hey
maybe i better be careful about quoting
too many quote liberals or maybe i
better be careful about what i write i
think it has a big impact on on the sort
of coverage you see and so that's a good
point
i think the charge
as i said earlier at the level of some
reporters at a beltway reporter may be
true in many cases in fact but to say
that the news is slanted terribly in
favor of the liberals it's complete junk
and i think it's a way of of keeping
people in line very effectively
um
you've articulated many
symptoms of a uh
our political culture did you examine
any of the um root causes for these
symptoms
about
well
the one common thread
we found was money i mean the one you
know campaign finance and the way the
political system operates that's a cause
that's not a symptom
i think in looking
in almost there's six chapters of the
book and in every one you'll see a lot
of attention paid to the issue of money
who gives these politicians money who
gives the lobbyists money that's an
issue i haven't really touched upon
tonight
but
you know the way that the political
system is financed the way political
candidates are forced to grub for money
um that affects congress and the
presidency of course
if you if you look at the press as i
discussed
you know we talked about symptoms in
terms of
the the high salaries are our causes in
terms of high salaries and the way that
the beltway press square has been
incorporated pretty much into the power
structure in many ways
in the area of lobbying too you see this
they're not historically i mean
it's fairly difficult to talk about a
debasement of standards amongst
lobbyists i mean these are people who
have no standards at all
so it's hard to talk about how terribly
the profession has has has been going
you know degraded during the last
several decades
but here too you do find it's i think
it's worse than ever in terms of the
standards of even the lobbyists i mean
you know you
you see people literally
telling any lie
for money ron brown i'm sorry to bring
up the departed commerce secretary but
you know it was striking in terms of the
coverage of ron brown when he did die
no one had the
decency if i can use that word to
actually tell the truth about ron brown
i mean believe me i'm not saying great
ron brown's plane went down of course
not
but you still are obliged to tell the
truth about him and you saw all of these
spawning
stories about brown well ron brown had a
very ugly
past ron brown was a lobbyist for patent
boggs and blow one of the big shops in
town
and he lobbied for uh baby doc duvalier
in haiti he lobbied for uh the
guatemalan sugar growers a group
basically a fascist in guatemala who
were complicit with the terrible human
rights abuses there for baby doc
he made ron brown made tens of thousands
of dollars lobbying for baby doc and
basically his job was to lie it was to
tell congress that baby doc was
improving the human rights situation
there and to try to get more money out
of congress more foreign assistance out
of congress for baby dog
and so you'll see
that
people in this town will do anything for
money and the amount of money available
to people who will do that
is is staggering and so i think that
that's one
root cause
the ability of people with money to
corrupt and influence the political
system and you see
so many different ways that they can do
that
you know another like grass
again lobbying maybe a better example
than than the last one grassroots
lobbying this is a this is going to be a
billion dollar a year industry soon it's
just sprung up out of nowhere where
lobbyists go out
and they create these bogus campaigns
they're supposed to be citizens
campaigns
and they go out and create these out of
washington dc or
you know if they go out into the field
they do it with a lot of corporate money
it's not disclosed and they pretend to
be you know like
citizens for a sound economy what a
wonderful name well citizens for a sound
economy is funded by
every
practically every member of the fortune
500 they get a ton of money from these
people
and for example let me during the um the
gas tax debate 1993
citizens for a sound economy went out
and joined in a campaign to defeat the
gas tax and they used money from oil and
gas companies who were horrified at the
thought that you know this would would
cut back on their profits they didn't
disclose any of the money
and they went out to places like
montana
and you know they they flooded the
airwaves with with ads calling people to
rallies and they they gave everybody who
came to the rallies sandwich and slice
of chocolate cake and they talked about
the devastating effect that the gas tax
was going to have on the state of
montana i was going to [ __ ] the state
you know it was going to cause all of
these unemployment and on and on and on
they didn't talk at all naturally about
the terrible effect it was going to have
on the companies that were secretly
paying their bills
and so at every level you see that the
political system has been corrupted by
people
with money and companies with money who
are able to
buy influence and push policy so that
that's the theme that you'll find
throughout the book
you know
yeah several people
um yeah several people have asked that
question i think we overlooked that
somehow in the book the only
the only person i think we uh
spoke very highly of in the book was
henry gonzalez the great populist texan
head of the banking committee
um until the republicans took over
congress in 1994.
he's an admirable guy here you know
written off as eccentric and sort of a
quack by a lot in the mainstream press
but here's a guy who took his job
seriously
and who was a fierce enemy of the banks
and the federal reserve and you know the
financial system he was a real critic i
mean he took his oversight
responsibility very seriously
and
he's someone in congress who i admire
personally a great deal you know there
are decent people i don't want to
imply that there's not a single decent
person running around congress who's
doing a good job and even some of the
people who i don't admire and whose
politics
i find contemptible
you have to admire at least for working
hard you'll even find surprises i mean
linda smith this republican
from washington state
and i think her views on social policy
are complete
completely bonkers and yet she's one of
the few people in congress who actually
says hey let's clean up the campaign
finance system and who refused to vote
for
a compromise bill that was a junkie bill
and that basically maintained the same
system and said no
we're going to really clean it up or
we're not going to do it at all and so
you know to a certain extent you have to
admire her for that um
i do think
there are
you know you could probably point to 50
or 60 members of congress
who really
take their job seriously
i think the number of people out there
doing that though
has been dramatically reduced because
it's just so hard it's so difficult i
think
and especially if you're not already in
congress to run now as an independent as
a crusading reformer as a populist boy
to raise the money to raise half a
million dollars to run for a house seat
that's got to be tough to do and so i
think you're going to see those numbers
keep dropping i think probably 20 years
ago you the number was a lot higher than
50 or 60.
and i do
you know there are people not in in the
non-government sector who certainly
you can point to i mean i personally am
a fan of ralph nader's i don't admire
him on across the board perhaps i may
criticize him on certain areas but you
know how can you not admire a guy like
nader who's been around for
the last 30 40 years
doing so much i mean there are people
out there doing great work and so again
i don't want to say that the whole
system is
is is hopelessly beyond reform i mean if
it were then there'd be no point in
trying to expose corruption
yeah
term
limits
i think you know this is one of these
things like the flat text where i'm very
skeptical about it
on the one hand
because of the people who tend to back
it like the coke family in uh you know
from kansas big backers of dole big
backers of
conservative causes i mean it's the they
own koch industries it's an oil and gas
um
company biggest private oil and gas
company in the united states they've
secretly funneled a lot of money to term
limits
you know i'm skeptical about it on the
one hand because
i think that there is something to be
said for
you know if people do a good job
why should they be booted um i guess on
the one hand people would say well the
longer you stay in washington you know
you become more corruptable and and that
may very well be true
i'm a little skeptical about it though
um i do
understand though boy i mean talk about
an issue that that people can respond to
in terms of kicking the bums out you
know it's it's got a lot of easy appeal
but i'm uh a little bit skeptical about
it you you had a question
uh yes i was going to ask you about um
pat robinson robertson and the christian
coalition and their influence on the
republican party and where their money
comes from
well
i wish i knew you know the christian
coalition like so many of these groups
is able to exploit a lot of loopholes
like citizens for a sound economy they
don't have to reveal
um
most of their funding sources because
they say we do grassroots lobbying you
know we don't go into congress and meet
with a member of congress and lobby on a
particular bill
we do grassroots lobbying where we
have phone banks
and and contact voters or we meet with
voter you know people out in the field
we hold rallies it's it's different so
there there's a huge loophole there
grassroots lobbyists
don't have to report who their funders
are um
you know i'm this may be not a popular
comment but you do again though have to
admire the christian coalition and
robertson on the one level
they have done a tremendous job of
organizing and it's too bad
that
you don't see the same sort of
organizing going on
perhaps from
people on the other side of the
political spectrum
i mean they have gotten people engaged
they have gotten people involved in the
political system
and i
there would probably be very few of any
issues where i might endorse their um
position
and yet
you know it's not enough to simply
condemn them you have to go out and
match them and
the republican party i think that's
overblown to a certain extent
but i think it's a trend that's probably
going to continue
you know if they had taken over the
republican party bob dole would not be
the presidential nominee of the
republicans and you wouldn't have seen
the dole forces so successfully shut
them down at the convention i mean
they're you know the christian coalition
and the the the right wing of the
republican party is terribly frustrated
because they haven't
been able to get on tv i mean they've
been totally shut down
i think they're probably the single most
important force
in the republican party but they're not
obviously
in control of the party
i think it's interesting at least to me
that this uh that you know they've been
propagandas my daughter was running for
office in in florida and they were
propagandizing in through the churches
and now
there's been a question raised i don't
know who but this is important that the
churches not be given certain
write-offs and taxes because this is
political and they've done this because
i know it was a fact oh no the christian
coalition and it's a terrible abuse this
is one of those other wonderful
loopholes in the system
the christian coalition
they can't be partisan
they can't say we support the republican
party or such and such candidate and of
course this is completely ridiculous of
course they're diehard republicans and
the same you know in fairness you can
say the same thing about a lot of the
liberal
non-profit groups in washington dc who
claim they're nonpartisan they're you
know hooked up with the democratic party
across the board
but the christian coalition
basically has gone out
leaf living you know they'll go to
churches on sunday and they put the
leaflet on the
on the
windshield you know so people come out
and they get the leaflet that will say
you know did you know that
joe blow
supports
you know killing hundreds of millions of
innocent americans because he's
in favor of abortion on demand and did
you know that joe blow
favors criminals
because he doesn't believe in the death
penalty
and of course joe blow is the democrat
and joe blow's opponent is the
republican but no we're not endorsing
the republican we're not working for the
republican i mean we're just presenting
the issues you know this is
so fraudulent and that the fec the
federal election commission now has a
lawsuit against the christian coalition
i'll be curious to see how far it goes
oh yeah that the ministers i my daughter
was telling were handing out the
material wasn't just in the parking lot
yeah sure no that's that's that's true
and it's just
you know it's it's it's a ridiculous
system and it's it's a loophole that
somebody should close but they never
seem to do it
um
you and then you
yeah i agree with what what you say
about big government
money and party politics what does it
say about our populist someone less than
50 percent of the people vote and what
in the future is going to change that
that you know that is
a fairly depressing commentary on the
state of american politics and i think
you do
you know i don't want to just say well
those people who don't vote
you know i can i can understand that
there are no choices i think that's why
people the the primary reason because i
feel like why should i go out
you know it may be raining out it may be
snowing i may want to stay home and
read a book or watch tv it won't matter
what i do
i don't think that's a good enough
excuse though
i think it's the primary cause
and yet you're right of course i mean if
people
if more people did vote i think you
would see
different sorts of people being elected
potentially i mean again
because of the current rules of the game
i mean the democrats republicans of
course write the election law
and so it's extremely difficult for a
third party to even get on the ballot in
many cases i mean there are some states
where
you know the number of signatures you
need to get a third party candidate on
the ballot is extraordinarily high and
then there are additional rules it can't
just be
you know it has to be a voter if you
sign the petition you have to have voted
in the previous primary and so you know
the rules are really very difficult and
then of course
you know the big one is if you don't get
five percent of the vote you're not
eligible for matching funds federal
funds
and so i mean here of course i mean i'm
in favor of public financing actually
but given that
you know the other parties get the
federal funding at the current currently
it's very difficult for a third party
you know you've got to start somewhere
you you know two percent in most
countries is good enough to get into the
parliament but in the united states
you're just written off as a complete
fringe candidate and so it's real hard
to break through as i said earlier
though i think
i wouldn't be surprised if by the year
2000 you you see the system broken down
or an accelerated process of breaking
down
so it was
um you mentioned a little bit earlier
about how the um
christian right has been shut down at
the republican convention just looking
at the coverage for the last couple of
days of that convention
um or the lack of any sort of
substantive coverage or any issues
really coming up how much of
that do you think is the republican
manipulation of the media
being effective and how much do you
think is just sort of the media
either through cynicism or acquiescence
saying okay we're not going to push
about
flip-flopping on
reducing the tax rate or we're not going
to push about dropping the platform on
diverse opinions
from the party platform
do you think that's
more than their manipulative ability or
sort of maybe just a cynicism and
acquiescence on part of the press well
it's a it's a combination of both i
think you know it is true it's sort of
funny to me to be you know you see
elizabeth dole give this speech and you
see various people give speeches and the
next day there's this
you know
god how many
trees have been cut down to you know to
cover the republican convention
you know this pointless coverage
you know and
on and on and on about the whole
spectacle
you know i do think there's been some
criticism
i watch a little bit of the networks and
there's been some criticism but it's
true they basically followed the script
i think the media is complicit because
they they should simply not agree to
follow that i mean if you remember
during the reagan years
and everything reagan did was scripted
we now know because he was
you know in advance stage of dementia
and was incapable of stringing together
more than a few sentences but
the media should not have collaborated
with the republicans at that time i mean
they
allowed them
to wheel reagan out to say hello to say
10 words and to go off you know they
allowed the republicans to stage events
during the campaigns with reagan
um and i think they should have said no
we're not you know if you go
and what reagan is wheeled out and you
know he's got a hard hat on and he's
driving some piece of plant equipment
for 30 seconds we're not going to film
it we're not going to put it on the
evening news because it's not news but
of course they do go they do film it
they do put it on the evening news so i
think the
parties are very sophisticated
at manipulation i mean everything is
scripted of course the convention down
to you know minute by minute
and the media effectively collaborates
um
with that by by allowing it to happen
did you i mean i take more questions i
don't know what your if you
well how about if we take what uh what
time is it
how about if we just take three more is
that
uh current turn limits as attractive as
they may sound from the standpoint of uh
allowing more people to serve and the
last analysis is only likely to worsen
the situation because if you get a a
grasping would be corrupt politician in
office and he only has six years to set
himself up after which he's out on his
ear he's going to be more beholden to
the corporations for post job
post-congressional positions and that
kind of thing on the other hand if you
get a henry gonzalez the the occasional
person like he only has six years he's
out after that
there's less motivation for somebody to
would otherwise perhaps push himself
into a position of some authority and
figure he'd be able to stay in it for a
while
no i agree with you that's why i said
i'm i'm i'm fairly skeptical about term
limits i mean
i think it's one of those solutions that
looks great
and the people go yeah let's throw the
bums out you know it seems like it makes
a lot of sense
i'm not so sure it really does and again
though you can understand certainly you
can understand the motivation for it
because people are so frustrated and
they want some way of exercising their
frustration and it is let's face it it's
very difficult to vote out an incumbent
because you know the big political
donors pour money into those
into the incumbent's campaign they have
a lot of advantages but yeah i mean if
you have if you put me on the spot and
said are you for against i'd say against
i'm i'm very skeptical about it
uh yes i was wondering what is the
reason for the big push to expand nato
to poland is this because
large defense contractors want to sell
the f-16 there where's the threat
cold war is over
well it would be nice the cold war is
over of course but you know the
the push for uh
for more and more
expensive weaponry
continues and so
i i have to confess i don't want to be
one of those pundits on this sunday
talking head programs who talks about
something he knows nothing about i don't
know what
is the reason that there's this push to
include poland and nato i mean i suspect
it's um
as partly as you say
you know another client um and i suspect
it may be
partly that there's you know that idea
of the permanent barrier another barrier
against possibly russia you know you
don't know what's going to happen to
russia but
i don't know i mean i do think though
that
you see that
the the politic the defense defense
system is basically a system of um
you know doling out contracts to to to
the big contractors who um
you know
again i mean i'm sorry to harp on this
tune who are able to through their
political contributions
um
get a lot of favors in washington you'll
see one thing you may hear about
in the next few years is uh
there's this guy at the pentagon named
andrew marshall
and he heads the office of
i think it's called the office of
strategic assessment it's in this is
again in the book
and you know he's come up with this
whole
new rationale
we don't need smart weapons anymore we
need brilliant weapons
you know what this means is more baroque
gold-plated weaponry
junk weaponry that most of it doesn't
work but it cost a fortune one of his
brilliant ideas
there was a story in the wall street
journal
one of his brilliant weapons
was a
a brilliant
missile
that was going to home in on the sound
of russian tanks
he would hear the sound of the engine
from far away and it was going to home
in on these tanks and destroy them
i talked to a guy who quit the pentagon
because he was so fed up with the amount
of waste and fraud and he said oh yeah
that's really brilliant you know they're
going to spend about a billion dollars
to develop it he said it's going to cost
50 bucks to defeat it you'll just put
out a pair of cheap speakers to mimic
the sound of a russian tank
the engine and the brilliant weapon is
going to home in on it and blow it to
smithereens
there was another weapon
and this is also in the book i don't
remember it was one of these brilliant
weapons that um
that homed in it was a heat-seeking
missile it was going to home in on
the aircraft engine you know it it it
seeks heat
you know so it's going to go after the
aircraft engine well they were testing
it i think was the maverick
um
but they were testing it in the field
unfortunately it was not armed but this
missile homed in on a poor group of
soldiers who were sitting around a
campfire cooking beans you know it
latched on to the the heat and the the
fire and if it had been armed it would
have blown them to smithereens so you
know these brilliant weapons these smart
weapons are
time and time again you'll find that
they don't work
they're complete junk the c17 c17 the um
the uh
oh it's this immense uh it's supposed to
transport troops and equipment tons and
tons and tons of it it's got 19 onboard
computers
he's got all sorts of stuff it was
supposed to cost 20 million dollars each
now it cost like 157 million dollars
each mcdonald douglas is making a
killing on it well the c-17 has this
mysterious center of gravity problem
it can't take off
unless there's
what the what the what the crew calls
the pet rocks they've got two eight-ton
rocks
you know cement
they're not rocks they're men's cement
blocks that they keep in the plane
because it can't take off unless it's
fully loaded
so
you know this is a sort of junk that the
pentagon pushes because it enriches
mcdonald douglas and the other
contractors so one more question and
then
yeah
about the drug war
it seems obvious to most people even
like some conservative magazines like
the national review the drug war has
been a colossal failure
why are we still continuing the drug war
well that you know good question what a
simple answer though
you know it's great politics i mean god
you know bill clinton
can make
and and the republicans make huge
capital on this issue i mean the
statistics show in fact that crime is
actually declining
but you never know it from reading the
newspaper from listening to the
politicians speeches i mean you know
it's huge political capital i mean you
know lock them up and throw throw away
the key that's three strikes in your out
system
i mean this is complete madness you're
going to lock up people in california
you know their third offense is stealing
a pizza but you know it's it's a great
political issue politicians cannot stay
away from it and so you see this madness
and that's i think the drug war as well
yeah everybody
including
thoughtful conservatives recognize that
it's a complete failure but you know i
wouldn't bet that it's going to uh
go away because too many people stand to
benefit from it
so
anyway i've been babbling on for quite a
while i should stop and
um you know if people want to buy the
book i can
sign it
and also one final one final thing even
if you don't want to buy the book
um you can get a free copy of the
newsletter that i work on with my
co-author alexander coburn counterpunch
and check that out and maybe you'll buy
those up here
okay i just want to thank ken for coming
by i'm sure some of you are growing
anxious and want to rush home to catch
the talent of the republican convention
but uh those of you who want to linger
and either ask a question or get a book
signed or even just say hello just come
on up and he'd be happy to do so
we have the list up here if you'd like
to get more information about borders
political events and we have the
counterpunch newsletter so thank you for
coming and we look forward to seeing you
again
in a minute you'll hear from a man who
took a motorcycle trip through post-war
vietnam then wrote about it in a book
called sparring with charlie motorbiking
down the hote